my name is uh na rabota p or masha cada
the Minister of Economic Planning and
Investment Promotion republic of
zimbabwe issues i want to speak on earth
to do with the leadership you are in
Africa Africa is a great continent and
we need leadership in your leaders we
can with a vision to carry the continent
forward leaders who can make sure that
Africa tells counted among other
continents the leaders who can harness
the people's potential and the resources
of their countries for the upliftment
upliftment of the lives of their people
so this forum the World Economic Forum
is really a good platform for us really
to revisit the issue of leadership in
you are in Africa thank you